moi j'ai une excuse pour pas aller en
soirée je propose de venir avec Gilles
Verdez généralement la personne elle l'a
mis dans les 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
il fait chier dessus
[Rires]
un drame à TPMP comme ça parce que vous
savez que j'adore le foot j'adore le PSG
il y a quelques années à deux trois ans
j'avais dit c'est les jours de jouer
enfin je devais venir à TPMP un mardi
soir un mercredi soir et le PSG jouer ce
soir-là évidemment pour moi c'était
impossible de rater même les la première
demi-heure des missions donc j'ai fait
croire je vis le premier truc qui m'est
venu c'est de dire j'avais une coulante
enfin la chiasse quoi et donc j'ai dit
ça évidemment vous n'en croyez pas un
mot mais quand vous la prenez c'est trop
tard vous m'appelez etc et le lendemain
matin vous m'appelez pour me dire
Jean-Michel tu te fous vraiment de ma
gueule j'ai pas cru une seule seconde à
ton excuse je serai Michael PSG jouer
etc je suis cramé c'est foutu mais
malheureusement qu'un jour plus tard
match retour et là j'ai vraiment la
chasse
je ne peux pas le dire parce que là je
me dis cette fois-ci je vais me faire
virer je suis venu non c'est pareil je
me suis chié dessus pour vous
c'était là j'étais à la place de 500
là ça arrive souvent
de venir
allez on voulait une bonne anecdote
allez Belgique
moi je vous ai menti
je vous ai menti je crois que je voulais
déjà raconté mais une fois je suis pas
venu l'émission et ah oui pour Los
Angeles
toute l'histoire en fait parce qu'en
fait j'ai dit que j'étais pas là parce
que j'étais non je dis que j'étais
malade que j'avais un problème de santé
et pourquoi m'avait appelé ce soir-là je
ne sais pas j'ai dû vous manquer
c'est ça moi je vous ai sentir les
choses il m'avait appelé et en fait je
sortais d'un rendez-vous parce que pour
le coup j'avais rendez-vous avec un
producteur américain et qui je voulais
vendre un jeu que je n'ai jamais vendu
comme d'habitude
je n'ai fait que ça et en fait j'ai vu
quand j'ai vu votre je vous jure que
c'est vrai quand j'ai vu votre nom il
est donc 11h du matin à Los Angeles que
j'ai vu votre nom j'ai il faut que je
réponde mais tu es où bordel et ben j'ai
dit parce que la sonnerie c'est pas la
même c'est pas la même je suis pour des
rendez-vous médicaux il me dit tu as
intérêt d'être là demain donc j'étais à
Los Angeles et j'ai donc tout laissé sur
je veux que c'est vrai j'ai tout
abandonné l'hôtel mes affaires la valise
j'avais mon passeport j'étais
directement à l'aéroport et j'étais là
dans latin pour la petite anecdote j'ai
dû dépenser un billet en supplément
comme je peux pas voir 500000 merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
alors les Chéries Delphine non moi quand
j'ai un ami vous j'ai pas envie d'aller
je dis je suis désolé j'ai un imprévu je
dis pas je dis pas quelque chose en
particulier non et du coup ça passe
parce qu'on se dit soit c'est travail
soit c'est c'est un imprévu
j'ai un imprévu
oh le relou il est relou non mais vas-y
non mais moi tu es folle ou quoi ça
passe pas du tout et vous Béatrice aux
États-Unis
je ne mens plus c'est comme vous je dis
la vérité il y a quelques jours encore
il y a notre ami Myriam qui m'a envoyé
tout à l'heure
dîner franchement je l'adore et j'avais
juste pas envie de sortir et voilà je
dis la vérité toujours et vous le savez
et parfois la vérité dérange parfois
Daniel qu'est-ce que tu dis toi bah moi
je suis pas tu as pas trop de
rendez-vous donc
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
excuse de tournoi de paddle très tôt
parce que c'est souvent très tôt les
tournois de paddle donc vous pouvez pas
mettre une excuse je prends pas de
rendez-vous moi en fait
personne à part avec Daniel le 8 mars